so let's now actually talk about that
the situation with the virus is getting
to the point where there is now a
blanket recommendation from the head of
the w-h-o for people aged 60 plus to
simply avoid crowded areas period this
is dr. Ted Rose a de nom de Brea Seuss
who says that people sixty and over
should stay off of trains buses even
potentially supermarkets to avoid
contracting the virus tweeting yesterday
quote if you are sixty plus or have an
underlying condition like cardiovascular
disease a respiratory condition or
diabetes you have a higher risk of
developing a severe case of the virus
try to avoid crowded areas or places
where you might interact with people who
are sick also adding to reduce your risk
from a new infection if you're sick stay
home
eat and sleep separately from your
family use different utensils and
cutlery to eat if you develop shortness
of breath call your doctor and get care
right away this is not the type of
advice doctors give when there is no
reason to be concerned and in the
meantime here in the United States we
are now up in over 100 cases so far as
of right now and this number may change
by the time you listen or watch listen
to or watch this six people have died in
terms of the age demographics it's still
overwhelmingly effecting an older
population with the most serious cases
the death rate for those up to 39 is
0.2% those in their 40s have a death
rate of 0.4% those in their 50s 1.3
percent in the 60s it's 3 point 6
percent and if you're in your 70s
there's an 8% death rate in the 80s it
is anywhere from a 15 to 22 percent
death rate among the young it is also
presumably weighted towards those with
pre-existing and underlying conditions
and in terms of those the death rate if
you get the virus with cardiovascular
disease is 10 to 13 percent that's
serious followed by diabetes death rate
of 7 to 9 percent respiratory disease 6
to 8 high blood pressure 6 to 8 and
cancer 5 to 8 among those
without pre-existing conditions the
death rate appears to be right around 1%
median age outside of China for cases is
45 among hospitalized patients the
median age is 56 now there have been
some strange rumors spreading for
example that black people may be
naturally immune this is not true it
just hasn't started to spread in African
countries and that is causing some
confusion Algeria had three cases
otherwise not many cases in Africa at
all and it is not true that black people
are immune in case you fell for that one
yesterday at multiple CVS is here in the
Boston area as well as Whole Foods all
hand sanitizer totally sold out now this
is less about whether hand sanitizer is
effective by the way then more about the
panic that its building there are people
tweeting that hand sanitizer kills
bacteria not viruses at the same time
there are reports that high alcohol
content hand sanitizer 90% or more does
kill most viruses but then there are
other reports that it kills most viruses
but not this one but the general idea is
the panic that has spread there's also
the general idea about hand-washing with
soap just being the best thing to do and
that's true there's a practical
difficulty of when you're out in public
and you touch your phone and you touch
your groceries and you touch money and
you hand your credit card to someone and
they hand it back and then you grab the
shared half in half to put in your
coffee which 100 people have touched it
is more difficult in public when even
going to public bathrooms you're likely
to come up against a lot of other
people's germs but certainly it seems
that hand-washing is the best activity
one can undertake let me know what you
are doing about this if anything I know
a lot of people doing nothing for the
time being we will have maybe a poll or
some kind of survey on our Instagram
page at david pakman show and while
you're there follow me on instagram at
david pakman one of our sponsors today
is VIN Chara watches giving you 15% off
your entire order when you go to david
pakman.com
calm /watch don't pay thousands of
dollars for a high-quality watch that
looks great because you don't have to
all of in Cera's watches are made with
high-end materials masterfully built and
they look like something you'd spend a
ton of money on but ever even chera
watch ranges from about a hundred and
fifty to three hundred bucks I went over
to their website and picked out the
bellwether in silver and white really
nice elegant look it's a coronagraph
style wore it to a gala over the weekend
and a lot of people ask me where's the
watch from really really great look
totally different they also sent me the
altitude in matte black and red a much
more rugged view of what a watch can
look like really liked it as well as
well as the athletic strap it's a new
year it's a new decade it's time to
re-establish your style add something
new to your look and a high-quality
watch is the perfect way to do that you
can get 15% off inch arrows entire
collection when you go to david
pakman.com slash watch